happy Friday cs19 how are you guys doing
today
awesome I appreciate that I also
appreciate it because I know it's a
Friday and I know it's a Friday before
the midterm so wow do I appreciate you
guys coming to class thank you so much
um a couple quick things before we jump
into things because it's a Friday I'll
start by telling a story as always
um and I think the last time I told you
the story of how I met my wife is that
right but where do we end up
did I get in the the truck
and did I make it all the way to Romania
oh okay so then like I get to Romania
and there I run into my wife again and
she's so well she's not my wife at the
time I run and I say hi I made it and
then I got this wonderful story to tell
her about how I took all these trucks
and I think she was very impressed
um and and at this point it just was a
great reunion uh we had a about four or
five days together it just felt
fantastic but as life would have it she
continued to have these exciting plans
she was going to go working at a refugee
camp in Hungary for a while uh and and
we thought we were going to go different
ways and we went different ways again
but the most serendipitous thing
happened
a few days later I was in a train in
Hungary in the middle of the night and
it's kind of cold and just mind my own
business and I'm talking a little bit to
the person in the car with me
and then Laura shows up apparently she
had gotten into the same train and the
same random part of Hungary the same
night and sat down in the car right next
to me and then she heard my voice she
was like what the person who came all
the way by the trucks to come find me in
Romania like how did you end up here and
so at this point we're like oh my gosh
the world like has brought us together
in so many different ways we ran to each
other on the island a bunch we managed
to make it to Romania together now we
ran to each other on train and at that
point we decided hey what if we like
intentionally ran into each other so
even though she was going to a different
destination than me we decided hey let's
go meet up and then we met up and we
started traveling together and then you
know our past didn't really go that
different ways uh until this day so
that's the second part of the story of
how I met my wife and I'd suppose even
though there's this really cute meet
cute certainly the more interesting part
of the story is the one where we got to
intentionally choose to spend time
together and I got to know this
wonderful woman and all those moments
those are the really special things I
mean cute is just like a nice but that's
not important right now what is
important is oh boy do we have a cool
lecture for you guys I appreciate you
guys coming to this lecture right so I
want to give you something very useful
very cool we're going to be learning
General inference in particular you're
going to be learning a particular an
algorithm called rejection sampling you
guys might know some of the other
professors at Stanford but I was talking
to a professor
um Noah Goodman who's one of the more
famous modern statisticians of our times
happens to also be at Stanford and we
were talking I said you know I think
this is something I really want to bring
into our intro probability class because
I think it clarifies so much and he says
yeah if there is one thing that I
thought all interests probably people
should see earlier it's this idea of
rejection sampling so you're going to
see a beautiful idea with Noah Goodman's
stamp of approval
in today's class we're going to do two
things we're going to finish our
conversation about correlations and
we're going to be learning about
rejection sampling
and it really comes around this
beautiful idea that you guys saw on
Wednesday called Bayesian networks and
in case people lost the plot I put the
whole plot line up here on the board
so the whole plotline of what we're
doing is we would like to be able to
solve beautiful interesting real world
problems with the power of probability
tools
but most real world problems have a lot
of random variables that in itself
shouldn't be too big a problem except it
leads to this interesting computational
problem one of the most straightforward
ways to represent many random variables
together is a thing called a joint table
and a joint table is exponentially large
so as you have bigger worlds that you
want to represent a joint table would
need exponential numbers of
probabilities that's both a space issue
and you'll have to exponential amount of
work in order to estimate those big
problems how sad we wanted to do this
but we can't
enter this great idea of Bayes Nets that
we saw on Wednesday and Bayes Nets is a
way to represent a probabilistic model
for a real world problem but it has this
beautiful property that it's going to be
o of n in terms of n the number of
random variables so Bayes Nets allowed
us to do probability for real world
problems now that leaves two to Do's for
you guys you would need to know how to
create a base net and you need to do
this task that we call inference but
inference is just a fancy word for
saying do conditional probability in the
context of this big random variable if
you guys have plot line questions please
do ask me
now towards this idea of a Bayes net the
key concept was if you can have some
expression of which random variables
cause which other random variables you
can really compress how you represent
the joint distribution
but that would require you to be able to
create a base net and there was this
side plot in Wednesday's class and I'd
like to pick up on it
oh and of course there's lots of real
world problems that you could think
about but our running theme has been
WebMD so WebMD you say a bunch of
symptoms and it can tell you for all the
possible diseases the probability of you
having all those different diseases
the Bayesian Network was defined in a
few ways
one of the ways is defined is first you
take all your random variables and you
make them nodes in a graph
and then we're going to draw lines in a
directed way
from nodes that we think are causally
impacting other nodes so we think flu
causes you to have fever and flu causes
you to be tired now there is a big
asterisk here in the O of n is that this
o of n kind of assumes that you don't
have too many arrows so if you have a
sparse number of arrows then you get the
nice compression
once you draw arrows you have to give
the probability of every random variable
given its causal parents and if you do
that that's your compressed way of
representing the entire joint
distribution
so for every probability give it the
probability of the node given its
parents so for example tired has two
parents flew in undergraduate for every
combination of values for its parents
you have to give the probability of
tired but if you do that for every
random variable you define a joint in a
very compressed way wonderful
there is a semantic way of thinking
about these Bayes Nets why they're so
amazing and one way to think about it is
that they're genitive they tell you the
story of how the joint comes to be and
the story that's told here is first
people have these priors whether or not
they have the flu or whether or not
they're undergrad and then we generate
whether they have fever from those so
it's like the world gets generated from
top to bottom and I really like this
idea of thinking generatively and
thinking about the process which from
which a joint is created
it's not just for WebMD you know there's
lots of different situations where
people might use these like the figuring
out why you have a communication loss
um or battery failure for
um how systems can go down or maybe you
care about you know detecting whether or
not there is a chemical uh in a
particular particular matter in the air
for all these things you might want a
basement they're very powerful tool it's
just a general way of thinking about
probability and what a language to have
so if you want to be working on this
skill creating a base net we have to be
able to come up with a structure but
then we also have to Define for every
random variable it's probably given its
parents
you can express that in a few ways you
can express it mathematically or you can
express them through code what a time to
be alive and then of course as we
mentioned
the Assumption in the Bayes net is that
if you take the probability of every
random variable given the values of its
parents if you multiply all those
together that's where the joint comes
from
so it's a simplification of how to
express the joint
okay that's where we left off
what we haven't really talked about is
how do people in the real world design
these like if I gave you a data set you
could make a Bayesian Network but you'd
maybe know the causality if you know the
causality you're done just draw your
nodes and and put the causality but I
want to give you a real world data set
where people might want to design the
Bayesian Network the real world data set
I have for you guys is all these people
in the UK saying what sort of Music they
want so every row here is a person in
the UK saying one to five do I like
dance music folk music country music
classical music musicals pop and so on
and you'd like to have a model of how
all these random variables are
interacting together
making a joint table would be too hard
but if you could come up with a Bayesian
Network which says how these different
random variables might be causing each
other you could express this entire
complex system in O of n space
if you could design this great you have
an expression from which we can solve
probability questions we'll start to be
able to say things like okay you listen
to a punk song therefore I think you
like Punk which will change my belief in
all these things and I'll have a better
belief of whether or not you like reggae
or Opera and you'd be able to do all
these wonderful inference tasks if you
could design it now maybe you just know
how music works and maybe you just sit
down and be like okay people who like
plop music also like you know class
music like Opera dancing music they
maybe like punk music too and like maybe
you can just design this from scratch
but one of the cool ideas we touched on
at the end of the day yesterday's
classes there are data driven things
that I do when I'm given a data set to
try and inform my decisions and one of
them is I take every random variable
and I see how much it co-varies with
other random variables so if one random
variable tends to if for like a person
they tend to be more Rocky
then how does that change my belief in
whether or not they're into classical
music or dance music or you know
alternative folk music
it would be great if we had a statistic
and I do have a statistic that I
calculate for every pair of random
variables
um
that particular statistic that we talked
about lightly I just want to finish the
conversation on is called covariance
and covariance measures for two random
variables like let's say x axis is how
much somebody likes heavy metal Rock and
y-axis is how much somebody likes let's
say Punk
when people tend to deviate from the
mean in a positive direction so they're
more likely to like heavy metal Rock
than the average person they're also
more likely to like rock uh than the or
sorry Punk than the average person so
these two random variables when people
deviate from a mean they tend to deviate
in the same direction and we can measure
that we can quantify what we want as
this it's like the expectation of the
product of the deviations of the means
in both directions and if you were to
then rework the mathematics of what this
is you would get that it's equivalent
statement to take the expectation of the
product of the random variables minus
the expectation of one times the
expectation of the other something you
could calculate from data
and this is a measure that people use to
try and suss out our two random
variables related I want to talk about
this a little bit because it's just a
cool concept and something that you're
going to need later on so it's a cool
concept buried in this idea of Bayesian
Networks
can I just tell you a little bit about
this number so there is this number you
can calculate for any two random
variables and when I see a high value of
that random that number I think those
two random variables are very related
when I see a very high negative value
I think that those two random variables
are related but in a negative way so if
you see one random variable becoming
High you expect the other random
variable to go low
but when I see a zero it turns out
there's a complicated analysis I think
that there's one of two things going on
either they're not related or the
relationship is somehow not captured by
this number
can I give you an example of two very
related random variables whose
relationship is not captured by this
measure of how much two random variables
Co vary
okay here it is it's not uh there's not
a beautiful picture to go with it but
it's a simple idea
imagine I have a random variable that's
negative one zero or one equal
probability so one-third chance of being
each of those things
on its own that's fine to think about
and I'm going to have a second random
variable and it's so related to the
first random variable that if you tell
me what x is I will tell you what Y is
if you chose X to be 0
then Y is going to be one if you chose X
to be anything other than zero Y is
going to be zero are these two random
variables related
oh yeah one is defined in terms of the
other one's value so if you tell me X
your belief in y will really change in
fact you'll know what Y is
they're not independent at all but I
just want to show you the limitation of
this measurement so X it's a one-third
chance of being negative one one-third
chance of being zero one third chance of
being one
Y is going to be determined based on X
and it turns out because
um as long as x is 0 then Y is one
there's a one-third chance that Y is one
and a two-thirds chance that it's zero
what you have in front of you is the
full joint probability table
if you were to calculate
the covariance you'd first get the
expectation of X well the expectation of
X you're going to take each of these
numbers and weight it by its value good
times expectation review know how to do
that by Tuesday
what if you wanted the expectation of
why what a reasonable thing to want well
why can take on two values zero and one
and it takes on zero with the
probability two-thirds and takes on One
with probably one-third so it's
expectation of one-third not so bad
now
no matter what
value X is or if x is zero then why
something non-zero but if x is non-zero
then Y is zero one of them will always
be zero
so if you multiply X and Y no matter
what value X was
that product will be zero so in all
cases the product of X and Y is zero so
the expectation of X and Y is zero
now if you want to calculate this
statistic we've been talking about this
measure of covariance it would be zero
minus zero times one-third which leaves
you with zero
so covariance it's supposed to be a
number which captures how much these two
variables Co vary it's in the freaking
name and yet even though these things
are very deterministically related
covariance ends up being zero what's
gone wrong here
covariance is one number to capture a
very complicated concept if you have
very large values of covariance or very
large negative values that is Meaningful
but covariances of zero could mean one
of two things
either there's no relationship
or it or there is a relationship but
somehow the covariance is washing out
and there's a very fancy proof that
shows that this is going to be zero if
there is somehow a very non-linear
relationship but that's a little bit
beyond the point of cs109 the point of
cs109 is you need to know that there's
this thing covariance between two random
variables I want you to think about it
when you want to construct a Bayes net
as a way to get information and I want
you to be able to interpret those values
and I want you to know that even though
covariance is a signal of relationship
covariance of zero could mean a few
things it's not a proof that they're
independent yes
um it will not be what a good question
so that's the first problem is this one
and the second problem that we're going
to talk about in a second is that it's
not bounded covariance could be a large
or small number so let me
give you a concrete example of that uh
here is weight and height for some
people and you know you could calculate
the covariance which says to what extent
do these two random variables vary
together
and you can get the covariance formula
and you can calculate each of the terms
and then you can get a covariance of 46.
and you're like does 46 mean anything is
46 large is smaller than like 2 000 but
it's bigger than like five I don't know
is this a meaningful number and people
thought about this for a while and they
thought okay even though covariance is
semantically something we care about
people don't know how to interpret these
numbers so come along a very fancy
person who came up with a very fancy
idea
there is something called the Kashi
Schwartz inequality which the proof is
beyond cs109 but the conclusion is this
if you calculate the covariance of any
two random variables it is always going
to be less than the standard deviation
of one random variable multiplied by the
standard deviation of the other random
variable and it's also always going to
be larger than the negative of that it's
not possible for them to be bigger than
this product proving that's beyond class
but the results of that is a different
number that you've heard about you've
heard about this thing called a
correlation
and the correlation is just a normalized
version of covariance we take the
covariance and we divide it by this
number why this number because we know
that the covariance will always be less
than this number
why is that nice correlation is a scaled
version of covariance which is always
between negative one and one
which is great
um if you go back to this plot
I actually used correlation here instead
of covariance because I wanted
everything between negative one and one
so that everything was on the same scale
so correlation
is a scaled version of covariance and
covariance is your measure of how much
two random variables relate to each
other
okay and then since it's a Friday I just
have some like
relaxing chill let's laugh at
correlations
so one problem I've talked about for
correlations is
a correlation of zero doesn't mean that
two random variables are actually
independent of each other they could be
very dependent just their relationship
isn't captured by this particular way of
talking about them deviating from means
together but this is a little too some
times things have high correlations but
they're not at all related so if you go
into Data people have mind for funny
correlations and here's two random
variables that just happen to correlate
but we think there might not be a deeper
reason rock music quality and U.S oil
production so
apparently like the 1960s were like the
Golden Age of uh rock music and there's
a whole bunch of us crude made between
them this ends at 2007. but we don't
think that oil is causing rock music and
we don't think that rock music is
causing oil I'll ask you why there might
be high correlations for these things so
think about that for a second two other
things that that have high correlation
but maybe aren't that related per capita
consumption of cheese a number of people
who died by becoming tangled up in their
bed sheets unrelated but they tend to
have a high correlation
uh divorce rates and butter consumption
butter consumption is down so our
divorce rates is it a coincidence
Perhaps Perhaps not
um
does anyone know why these things that
seem unrelated might have high
correlations
yeah in the back
um there might be something else that's
causing them there could be something
else that's causing that it is possible
it turns out for these three there's a
different mechanism going on
excessive data yes like in five
relationships
yeah if I took a random number generator
and a different random number Jitter and
I generated a data set from them
they're probably going to be
uncorrelated because they're all random
but if I repeated this process a billion
times two random numbered generators are
going to produce two random two like a
random set of data and it'll just happen
to be that they look correlated if you
look for enough pairs of random
variables even if they're all unrelated
eventually just by chance you'll find
two that happen to be high in this
correlation thing so there's like we are
fishing through too many data sets to
find correlations anyways that's just a
fun aside
um but the real reason I brought it up
is because
when I look at a big data set and I
don't know how to model one of the pro
tips that I would use is I calculate the
correlation between every pair of random
variable to try and figure out which
ones are related to each other
foreign
so at this point in the plot
could you create a Bayesian Network well
sure there's a few options for the
structure you could either guess at
causality or you could calculate
correlations and you know again try and
artfully design a nice Bayesian Network
you then need to give the probability of
every child given's parents we'll talk
about that in a bit but at this point
sure you could create a base net if you
needed to
question
mathematical way to determine the
direction it's causality
is there a way to determine the
direction of causality a little bit
here's what's easy to do
you can disprove causality or it can
have a high probability that there's not
causality it turns out it's very hard
from historical data to say there is
causality um it's you know maybe you've
heard the thing like correlation does
not imply causation it's very hard to
pull out causality though it turns out
sophisticated mathematics can disprove
different causal relationships
yes
um last time we talked about um
like blue might cause you to be tired or
it might have you to my house
how does it work where um it's like the
opposite of like something causes
something not to happen like it's not
working yeah you'd still use causality
so if like I don't know taking a vaccine
will mean you're less likely to have flu
I would still cause that call that
causal even though it's like a negative
cause it's still one is really
influencing the and creating the value
of the other one
good question
but the day of the real point of today's
lesson is let's say you have a Bayesian
Network I want you guys to now be able
to solve any probability question you
might want to ask about it
one option is algebra so by Algebra I
mean like take this random this Bayesian
Network and you can just calculate using
pencil and paper or maybe a piece of
python any probability question we
talked about this one
where you compute The Joint just by Pro
calculating the probability of things in
order from parent to child so probably a
flu times probably of undergraduate
times probably a fever given
flu equals zero times are probably the
target equals one given that undergrad
equals one and flu equals zero if you
multiply all those things together you
get the probability of the joint it's
like the Bayesian Network is hiding
probabilities of joints it's a way of
representing joint probabilities
but if you wanted to do a conditional
probability we talked about this last
time
you can still do it using joint
probabilities
I mean using joint probabilities you
could know the probability of any
particular combination to all random
variables
and because of this you could use the
definition of conditional probability
this probability is equal to the
probability of everything divided by the
probability of the right hand side but
that probability of the right hand side
you can get through marginalization you
can take your joint and you can think
about the case of the right hand side
these three where flu equals one in the
case of the right hand side where flu
equals zero add those two things
together you marginalize out flu and
you're just left with the probability of
the right hand side
so that works it's one way to calculate
but what about this probability
so I have a little challenge for you
guys chance for warming up chance to
meet the person next to you
how would you calculate this conditional
probability I've given you a Bayes net
which means basically I've given you a
way to calculate the probability of a
joint could you calculate this
probability and I'd encourage you to
think well I've got the joints
if I write this in terms of conditional
probability could I use the fact that
I've got a joint to calculate each of
the things in my definition of condition
probably that I need you can go from a
joint to a probability of an assignment
to fewer random variables
think about it talk to the person next
to you and then we're going to come up
with something altogether
um
marginalized the marketplace
or
um
okay okay let's talk together
questions concerns what's confusing
about this
I wrote the definition of conditional
probability for the thing you're
supposed to calculate
and I want to remind you that
with a Bayesian Network or any
probabilistic model for many random
variables the first thing is to make
sure you can calculate the probability
of a joint which is if you're thinking
about it as like a programmer it's like
I'm giving you a function
if you give me assignment to all four
random variables I've got a function
which will give you the probability of
that joint assignment
what I don't have is a calculation for
the probability of just two random
variables
so I've got this I want these things
is there a way to go from one to the
other
you could use law of tool probability
yes it has another name it is the log
total probability but the log tone
probably has another name often when
we're talking about many random
variables together to say I want to
remember what that other name is
marginalization love till probably the
same thing it's just love total
probability applied to joints so if you
use marginalization it's a way to go
from the fact that you've got a
probability of many random variables to
calculate a probability with fewer where
you just don't know if somebody's got
fever or you don't know if they've got
flu
so
you know again
if you want to know the probability of
flu and fever you want to think about
all combinations of undergraduate and
tired
so you know one way of thinking about
this sorry
um this is for the top bit so this is
the one where you just don't have fever
so for the top bit it's like you're
going to add in Fever equals one with
fever equals two and if you add those
two probabilities together you
marginalize out fever and you're just
probably of this and this and this
fantastic
for the bottom we need to marginalize
out both flu and fever
and so it's like you Loop over all
possible combinations of flu and fever
and for each of them you calculate the
probability of those things you're
marginalizing out with the probability
of the things that you're holding
constant
and then you can end up with just the
probability
oh of undergraduate and tired yes you're
left with just the probably of
undergraduate equals one and tired
equals one marginalization allows you to
go from knowing probably many random
variables to knowing the probability of
fewer them yes
what does it mean to
me okay so I want this I Want U and T
what I've got is U and T and the two F's
so I know I need to marginalize out the
two F's
and to marginalize out I just sum over
assignments to the two F's so I'm going
to call X my assignment to flu and why
my assignment to fever so you have to
sum over the ones you don't want
take the joint some are the ones you
don't want and you're good
if you did this
if you did this then you would end up
with a probability that somebody has a
flu given these two assignments
this is great and you can definitely
calculate this but
it does get a little bit complicated you
know it can become really hard if you
had thousands of random variables and
you only observed two
you're gonna have to marginalize out
every unobserved random variable and
think about WebMD you can have pain in
your toes you could have a headache you
could have a stomach ache maybe you just
feel a little bit tired today or funny
like there's thousands of random
variables and we have to marginalize
them all up
okay and so if you have too many random
variables you have to marginalize them
all out this calculation is going to
become really really expensive
darn it we were doing so well we wanted
to be able to do inference and we wanted
to be able to do it in a scalable way
but right now even though we've got a
mathematical way of doing inference it's
not going to help us as computer
scientists we need to think of another
way and the beauty of the way I'm going
to teach you I will teach you a more
General way that is very powerful
but it also covers so many intuitions
about probability so if you can follow
along not only are you going to learn an
amazing randomized algorithm that will
teach you how to do inference for any
Bayesian Network
or any probabilistic model for that
matter it's also going to just like
teach us some good hearty probability
along the way
the very simple idea is we're going to
have this thing called rejection
sampling Step Zero
you have to define a Bayesian Network
and you have to Define it in code
to define a Bayesian networking code you
basically need to write all these
probabilities and you have to write a
function which can generate a sample of
the joint or calculate the probability
of a joint
the steps are going to be
maybe you're going to get an observation
observation from the user so the user is
going to tell you I observe
undergraduate and I observe that
somebody's tired there's no algorithm
here this is just the the user telling
you the puzzle you have to solve and now
we're going to try and figure out the
probability of the flu given their
observation
and there's a two-step process and it's
so straightforward you guys could have
invented rejection sampling yourself
the straightforward way is can you
generate me a whole billions and
billions of fake samples from your joint
and we're going to put that into a big
data set
so give me a billion fake examples from
your joint
and then to calculate any probability
I'm just going to resort to Counting
so it's got like a little bit from every
part of class you've got a bit from like
the probabilistic models part of class
you've got a bit from like the the
foundation part of class and a little
bit of counting for the beginning of
class and through all this you're going
to be able to do the inference task for
any probabilistic model it's going to be
that straightforward are you guys ready
for it
you should have two questions your first
question should be how do I sample a ton
and the second question should be how do
I do counting if I've got samples to
answer any probability question
shall we jump into the first one how do
we sample a ton
it's this easy if you want to sample a
ton you Loop many times and make one
sample and add that to your list you're
like oh Chris that's a very satisfying
answer
says nobody
why is this not a satisfying answer it's
like okay sampling a ton obviously
requires you to be able to create
samples what I really want to understand
is how do you create a sample
creating a sample means I'm just going
to generate one fake person and this
fake person we're going to observe
everything about them
we'll know if they have the flu we'll
know if they're undergrads we're going
to know if they have fever it'll know if
they're tired in fact we did this a
little bit on Wednesday's class
I showed you a function like this
and this function made me a fake person
Where You observe everything about them
You observe if they have a flu and
undergraduate fever or tired not that
they have another graduate whether they
are an undergraduate
if you run this it gives you one person
and it turns out that person's
probability of having this particular
assignment come straight from the joint
if you run this 10 times you'll get 10
people
where you'll observe everything if you
run this a hundred thousand times you'll
get a whole hundred thousand fake people
if you look at any particular assignment
like they have a flu they are an
undergraduate they have a fever and they
are tired like ones to everything
the probability of seeing one one one
one
will be the true probability according
to the Bayesian Network if you generate
a hundred thousand let's say the
probability of getting a one one one one
is truly ten percent
if you generate a hundred thousand of
these you expect to see 10 000 people
with a one one one one
sampling is such a nice intuitive idea
it's sometimes weird to think about but
do you guys know in prom set too where
you guys had to write a function which
would sample from a poisson like you'd
run the poisson function you're passing
a Lambda and it'll give you back a
number that's a sample and then you
wrote the exponential function and you
would run it and it would give you back
a number every time you ran it that's a
sample this is just a joint sample
instead of giving you one number it's
giving you a number for every random
variable okay this is half of the
algorithm so maybe you have questions it
would be great if you had questions I
would love to talk about it yes
I guarantee you that it's sampled from
your Bayesian Network
and if your Bayesian Network is any good
this will be a really good
representation of the real world if your
Bayesian Network is totally made up and
completely useless then so will these
samples be so if your beta Network's
good these samples will be good but they
perfectly represent the network
Yeah question how is bird implemented oh
Vern I count I get a probability
uniformly between zero and one
and so maybe when you pull a number
between zero and one you get like a
0.892
and if that number is uh
less than the parameter then I pass
return back one otherwise I return back
is here
yeah lots of good ways to implement Yeah
question
um how like how wrong would your
sampling is
you had to
the the children as the cause of parents
good question you know it's hard to
quantify but I tell you this is if I
were to try this out I might do
something like have a few Bayesian
Networks and maybe I'd have some people
for whom I know whether or not they had
the fever and I would try seeing which
Bayesian Network is leading to the most
accurate predictions but otherwise if
you flip the arrows you'd be wrong it'd
be so hard to come up with the
probabilities like the probability of
being an undergraduate given you have a
fever seems like a harder probability to
come up with
um
but even if you did it and if you came
up with reasonable probabilities you
would still get a reasonable answer
have you guys heard this this saying all
models are wrong but some models are
useful turns out the more realistic your
model looks the better your answers will
be but even if you're a little bit wrong
you'll probably get pretty good answers
causation
yeah what like what's like how does it
actually help that's creators I mean
it's an art form creating a network is
an art form it turns out there is this
algorithm called structure learning
which you'll learn about in cs228 where
you can just like learn the whole thing
purely from data and you try and do
things like learn different causal
patterns which can't be there there is
there are algorithms for that but I'd
say most people making Bayesian networks
it's art and love and dedication and
data so they'll look at the correlations
they'll come up with their understanding
of how the world Works they will
artfully create a Bayesian Network and
then they'll probably test it maybe they
make a few base networks and they'll
test them see which ones come up with
the best predictions
it's a good question and the real answer
is art and craft
but you need it because if you don't do
it you're stuck in something where you
can't even compute
yes
sunrise
your busy model and then you see if any
of those people can
well yeah now you're getting into my
second step all I've done so far is make
a bunch of fake people but the important
thing about the fake people is that for
every fake person I can see all of their
variables
hey how big is your computer
I'd say a hundred thousand will just
take you a second but if you wanted if
this is like life or death then maybe
you want to do like 200 000 I'm kidding
choice of views
uh there is a formal way to think about
how many you'd need and we'll talk about
that later but basically just recall if
you're making a fake person start with
choosing the values of the parents of
the node the network and then you choose
the children like flu is dependent on
whether or not sorry fever is dependent
on whether or not you had a flu so you
want to choose flu first
and tired is dependent on whether you're
not undergraduate and flu so you want to
make sure you choose tired after you
choose those two random variables and
after this you've sampled
I have explained to you half of this
beautiful randomized algorithm if you
guys want to hear the under half
the other half is called rejecting
that's why it gets its name rejection
sampling but just to be clear after I
call this part of the function I'll get
a whole bunch of fake people and in
these in this fake data set this was flu
this was undergraduate this was a fever
and this was tired everyone's tired
the second half is simply rejecting and
Counting
the simple idea is
if you want to figure out say the
probability of somebody having a fever
given their undergraduate and tired
you're going to go through all of your
100 000 fake people
and you're going to throw away every
data point that's not consistent with
these observations
recall when we taught you conditioning
what would the semantics of a
conditioning you enter the world where
these two things are true with your data
set you can enter the world where
undergraduate is true and tired is true
and you can do that by only looking at
the samples that are consistent with
those two things
so you take your hundred thousand you
throw out all the grad students you
throw all the professors throw out all
the babies but you know I just mean from
your data set and you throw out everyone
who's not tired and you're just left all
the undergraduates who are tired
that's the first step so you can call it
rejecting or you can call it keeping the
ones that are consistent so I'm going to
Loop over every sample
and I'm only going to keep the ones that
are consistent with my observation so
for every sample I'll see are you an
undergraduate and are you tired and if
so I'm just going to keep that sample
after this step cap samples will be
strictly smaller than 100 000. well
it'll be a hundred thousand or smaller
now you've got a small subset of data of
all the people who are consistent with
undergraduate tired and your simple next
step is
from that smaller data set
count how many people have the fever
so if you have let's say 30 000 people
in your fake data set who are
undergraduates and tired you're just
going to figure out the ratio of how
many of those have fevers so if ten
thousand of those people have fevers
then the probability of fever equaling
one
given undergraduate equals one and tired
equals one is just going to be equal
approximately equal to this ratio
and I'm done and you've calculated
conditional probability and the
beautiful thing about this is you can
change your observation you could
possibly even keep the hundred thousand
fake people
and you can calculate any conditional
probability you want for any network
who or what do you guys want to see this
thing in action okay let's do this no
more slides take me to the code
so here I have the same program it's
just now I use underscores instead of
camel case I fought that hard I switched
to python I still did camel case
everyone else did underscore snake case
I fought it hard but like I've finally
come around and I've drunk the Kool-Aid
and I'm one of the kids who does
underscores now not important what is
important is rejection sampling is a
cool algorithm
sampling and simulating a continuous PDF
from a different PDF wait wait wait
we'll talk about continues in a hot
second
good question though
I want to First just show you guys this
thing in action so I'm going to run it
it's called Joint sample you know when I
first taught this I didn't want to call
it rejection sample doesn't that sound
so mean like I don't like to reject
people that's not what I'm about I'm
about it's all the inference task but I
don't want to do any rejections so I
call it joint sampling but then I
realize that's not what people in
literature call it so now you know
here's the simple thing I
I get an observation from the user and
right now I just hard coded that
so I said my observations that somebody
has a fever and they're an undergraduate
but I don't know if they're tired and I
don't know if they're flu if I want to
say I observe that they aren't tired
then I would make this false
but if I put none it just means I don't
observe whether or not they're tired
do you guys want to give me an
observation we're trying to predict if
somebody has the flu
so we want to keep that one none okay
this person do they have a fever let's
just scale it and I'll just go with what
the mass says do they have a fever yes
oh poor them
okay are they an undergraduate no no oh
are they tired yes
well that's incredibly consistent okay
we have somebody who is not an
undergraduate but they are tired and we
want to know if they have a fever so
we're just going to sample a ton
we're going to throw out every sample
that's not consistent with our
observation and we'll figure out the
probability that they have a flu in this
case it says these people this person 95
chance definitely has a flu according to
your Bayesian Network
now you could try a different one I just
want to give us one other example
I'm going to show us having no
observation for tired in fact actually
should we do this one should we do
undergraduate equals one and tired
equals one but you don't know if they
have a fever
okay undergraduate equals one true
we don't know if they have a fever
but we know that they are tiring
so here none means you don't know and
true means you know and it's a one
okay undergraduates who are tired how
many of them have the flu
so you're just like I'm tired you
probably don't have the flu if you now
if you tell me you don't have a fever so
now you're saying I'm tired and I know I
don't have a fever I kind of expect that
probability to go down because now you
just told me more information yeah you
tell me you definitely don't have a
fever I'm like yeah it's probably just
tired
could be the flu one percent chance it's
the flu but you're probably just tired
yes
or not I feel like it was the same
process yeah when you were trying to
figure out for the jeans if they were
causing the trait what you guys were
looking for were independencies you know
what you guys were secretly doing you
were secretly trying to find the
structure of the Bayesian Network you
weren't necessarily calculating the
conditional probabilities that you would
need to pull out a sample like it would
be hard for you guys to sample one row
of that data set but once you have the
data set then yeah the conditional
probabilities were just counting like
the second step of this you use the
exact same thing for the bat data set so
first that about was just really about
creating a Bayes net and the Second Step
was about doing the second half of
rejection sampling you already had a
real data set you didn't have to
simulate it yes
do these like different trades have to
be
um independent like did you ever
integrate with like conditional problems
oh these things are very much not
independent
um there's a whole Bayesian Network that
is explaining their relationship so if
you're undergraduate that very much
changes our belief that you're tired if
you have a flu that very much changes
our belief that you're fired so you've
got a fever so you have a lot of things
that are very much related
taking the joint table work if it's like
if they have different conditional
problems
the conditional probabilities are
encoded here let me show you where
they're encoded there is a part where
you have to sample
where's my sample there's my sample oh
hi sample
so there's your part of your code where
you sample
and this is where all the probabilities
lie I'm saying the chance that you have
a flu and the chance you have
undergraduate the chance that you have a
fever given you have a flu the chance
that you have a fever given you don't
have a flu the chance that you have that
you're tired given this particular
setting of probabilities like I've
defined all these conditional
probabilities I've put them into Python
and I've put them in Python in a way
that I can create one sample
these conditional probabilities are true
for everyone the model is universal but
if you have a particular human being
they might show up and you might want to
do a query based on some traits the
model is universal the query is for a
particular individuals but the
conditional probabilities in the model
they'll be for everybody
good question yes
that's the second part this is the first
part which is generating a ton you guys
want to see the rejection part yes
yes okay here
perfect
yeah
over it yeah so I just go through all
the samples and I count how many people
have the flu and then I just return well
I didn't need to do a float but you know
so it goes
um you know the how many people have the
fluid divided by how many samples I kept
as you've got exactly right
okay
full rejection sampling uh to do
I imagine there's probably questions at
this point though so I really appreciate
them but it really comes down to
get the query from the user this
algorithm will handle any query for this
model
then we're going to sample a ton and
then we're going to calculate our
conditional probability just by
rejecting and Counting and then you can
solve any probability query you have for
this particular model
and the real challenge wasn't the
rejection part the real challenge is
only can you write the sample
and so if you have a Bayesian Network
and you can write this function which
does the sample from the Bayesian
Network then you can solve any inference
task so I'm going to put a little check
mark here I do owe you an explanation
for continuous random variables but
we'll get to that in a second
more samples if you know you're going to
reject more yes if you know you're going
to have to reject more you would need
more samples and that's why continuous
becomes so interesting
okay
so at this point
you know if I gave you
a thing like WebMD if you want to make a
Bayes net tell me how you think the
world's organized and then you need to
get your conditional probabilities you
can either talk to an expert or use a
data set for those then once you have a
Bayesian Network we can use rejection
sampling and answer any probability
question we've got
okay
so
here is the claim behind rejection
sampling it's not that crazy
the claim behind rejection sampling is
that this conditional probability is
about equal to how many samples are
consistent with the observation
and What proportion of those are
consistent with the observation and also
have flu equals one
and this really harks back to the
original definition of probabilities
which is saying that the probability of
our event of somebody having a flu is
the ratio of number of times that
happens this is in the universe of what
we observed so in the universe of what
we observed how how what fraction of
people have the flu so it's like
counting number of people of flu divided
by the number of people in this
particular universe so the universe of
people who are undergraduates and are
tired so the theory behind it's rather
straightforward and this is why
rejection sampling works
what does it require you to understand
you need to know what a Bayesian Network
is you need to know what it means to
sample from a Bayesian Network to get a
whole joint sample and then you need to
know the simple idea of counting
and then you can answer your inference
questions yes yeah
you know I might I can use Bayesian
networks to create interesting joint
probability questions so there's you
know things from your uh last section
where you guys talked about joint
distributions and a Bayesian Network is
just a really elegant way for expressing
a joint
would I make you guys do rejection
sampling on the midterm maybe not
because you know the code for rejection
sampling it's always the same
like this part of the code is always the
same the only part of the code which is
different if you were to do it
differently is to write this code where
you pull a single sample
would I make you write a code that could
pull a single sample I'm definitely
going to ask it for you in the next
problem set I think on the midterm I
probably wouldn't make you do this I
would possibly though
you know I think this is fair game this
idea that you can count to calculate a
conditional probability so if you have a
data set like the bats that we talked
about earlier you could get
probabilities by counting from subsets
that's very much fair game
good question
okay now
if you can sample Enough From The Joint
distribution you can answer any probably
question wow what a fun time but there
is a problem with rejection sampling
and the problem with rejection sampling
is if you condition off something
incredibly rare
so if you condition off something that
hardly ever happens and if in your
hundred thousand fake samples you just
didn't see the thing you condition off
of you'll reject everything
so imagine you're conditioning off like
a very rare occurrence like somebody has
a fever uh but you know maybe they don't
have a flu like this almost never
happens if you condition off that you
take your 100 000 samples you look
through all of them that has that
particular assignment and maybe you
throw away everything
and if you throw away everything you've
got a problem right because the
definition of probability here was
supposed to be
you know the limit as n goes to infinity
and if you've thrown out wait everything
you're left with like zero one two or
three samples this is getting pretty far
away from the definition of probability
that we were using
so the problem with rejection sampling
is if you reject everything kind of like
the problem with life
so let's think about this a little bit
and I can give you a particular version
of this which really breaks rejection
sampling and that's if I took my
Bayesian Network and I allowed for a
continuous random variable
fever is not something that's a one or a
zero it's a continuous number you say I
have a fever of 92. wait I have a c
fever of 102. you don't say I just have
a fever so what if we wanted to take a
Bayesian Network and we want to allow
one random variable to be continuous
we have seen Bayesian networks with
continuous random variables like for
example the elephant one we would have
weight as a continuous random variable
or in the gay is we how much the child's
view would move that was a continuous
random variable so we have seen it
before and the way we saw it were things
like this
if somebody has the flu
that's definitely wrong
if somebody does have the flu
then the distribution of their
temperature is going to be a normal with
a higher mean
and it turns out there's quite a bit
more variance if somebody doesn't have
the flu then the distribution of their
temperature is the average temperature
of a human but there's also variance to
the average temperature of a human some
people present with like 99 degrees even
when they're healthy
but when people have a fever you know it
could be anything from like 90 uh eight
to 102. there's a whole bunch of
variants so this is a more precise way
of expressing fever
does that make sense
okay so at this point we've got a
Bayesian Network could we still write a
sampling algorithm because that was the
first thing we need to do as I said the
most complicated thing we'd have to do
is a sampling out of the room could you
sample flu for a new person
yeah that's good can you sample
undergrads yeah it's just going to be
that burn 0.8 could you sample tired
well you know if they've got the flu you
know if they're undergraduate and we're
just using the same algorithm so yeah we
could could you sample fever
if you're making a joint sample
talk to the person next to you how would
you sample fever see if you can figure
it out and we'll just check or not check
if you can sample fever how would you do
it how would you rate this in Python
foreign
I don't know what you guys came up with
but it turns out the answer is yes you
can sample
here's what happens is you go back to
your sample you have to choose flu first
because flu is one we're going to be
sampling from different normal
distributions if flu is one we're going
to be sampling fever from a normal
distribution with that higher mean if
flu is zero we're going to sample from a
normal distribution with that lower mean
now Norm that's not a function here's
how you sample from a normal
scipy has a stats library and you can
see
stats.norm.rvs you just passed the mean
and standard deviation it will give you
a random sample from that normal
distribution
so can we sample absolutely the problem
isn't that we can't create joint samples
and if we go to our code
I'm going to now create an observation
my observation is somebody is an
undergraduate and they are tired and we
observe a fever of a hundred and one
and I'm just going to use the exact same
rejection sampling now we've got those
normal distributions assembled for fever
let's do this Python 3
joint sample continuous
Here Comes our fake people and look
they've all got temperatures how cute is
that it's like it's so much more
exciting oh there goes their numbers
um
that's not right
dude I might have played around with
this and I must have fixed something
because that probability is supposed to
give us a surprising result of a null
okay let's see my
check observation match
um
I'm not doing anything really fancy here
am I
sorry
print observation
dude oh wait I know what I did here
so cute oh my God so cute
so cute of Me no
okay
back to My Demo That was supposed to
fail but somehow didn't fail
no it really failed probability is not
defined
uh
terminal new terminal I feel like people
go to uh watch race cars because there's
a chance that they'll crash
okay here comes my fake people
and from these fake people we're gonna
reject everything that doesn't match our
sample oh no it broke and our sample had
this is the thing we were going to
condition off so we rejected everything
that didn't match this
and we look for exact matches you're
like wait something definitely matched
that and you go over and you're like um
and you're like that one that one
matches almost and you're like nope not
exactly like that one doesn't match and
you get to this one you're like that
matches right
no you condition off an exact match that
is the proper probabilistic thing to do
you went through all your samples and
you looked for a hundred and one point
zero we've talked about this for a
continuous random variable what's the
chance that it gives you exactly 101.0
zero that's never happening sad times
and so like sad times expressed in
computer science is here oh
division by zero when I went to count I
had rejected everything and I was just
left alone without any samples crying in
my bedroom division by zero
and then unfortunately I had
accidentally showed you the solution or
a solution
so a solution was what if every time you
generate somebody with a fever you round
it
so did you do does anyone remember the
math the function for rounding there it
is
there it is so oh well there's
definitely a nice function for rounding
but
um python has around and so you can just
take any free version if you round it
now when we create our samples
once they get rounded you have a
non-zero chance of people actually
matching 101.0 do many of these match
100 1.0
see a lot of people but you do see
enough that you can calculate a
probability if you don't see many 101.0
if that is a very rare event
how can it still be the case that the
probability of fever is very high
the thing I condition off is rare
but the probability fever was very large
sorry the probably flu was very large
because the thing I condition off is
rare doesn't tell you about the
probability of flu what that tells you
is I'm going to be rejecting a lot of my
samples so maybe you have a hundred
thousand fake people only a hundred of
them had that particular fever
temperature but when we looked at those
hundred people who have a particular
fever temperature a whole bunch of them
actually have the flu
so
going back to the theory maybe I should
answer questions there
ah I made it round
so what I changed here
is
when I generate my samples before I
would generate a continuous number to
full precision and I just generate one
to like one decimal point
yeah you could have like you could have
said fever is low medium high you could
have said your fever is 100 or you know
90 to 95 95 to 100 100 any way you
discretize would work and this is a way
of discretizing I'm just discretizing to
one decimal point so discretization is
helping us once again
yeah could you just explain how you
generated the random Beaver numbers oh
yeah so I used the the
let's check this line up
so I'm just gonna pull up python
so terminal python pyron whatever
from
PSI Pi import stats you want a random
you want a random normal
but what normal
give me a mean
ooh good choice standard deviation
no that's too big no I'm just joking
that's fine okay I'm going to call this
function and it gives you one sample
so um if I call it again you get a
different sample it's not always the
same number
and the distribution from which this
comes is the probability density
function
it's but it's not uniform
it's random from this particular normal
it's from the PDF of the normal
yes
oh random variables I think uh or random
values and I think there might be a
parameter where you can be like 10 and
it might give you back 10 of these yeah
the S is for multiple and because this
function allows you to get multiple
how optimized is my code you're like not
at all I could definitely optimize this
but the point is the learning not how
fast you could run this
okay
wait I want to talk more about this so
if you guys have questions this is very
fun
so this is the thing we're trying to
learn how to do any inference task for
any Bayesian Network and rejection
sampling is such a good idea it requires
you to know how to do two things you
need to know how to sample
and then you just need to write
rejection sampling it fails if you're
doing a query where the condition thing
is so rare you throw out all your
samples and so we used a trick here to
solve that problem
questions comments concerns yeah
that's a good question yeah you know I
had I think I made a hundred thousand
samples so that discretization gave me
enough samples for each reasonable thing
but you know if I had if I want to make
a billion samples I could probably get
away with a finer discretization so it's
dependent on how many samples you have
it really comes down to what's the
probability of your observation and if
that probability gets too low it fails
or you need more samples
yes is there a way that we can do this
without discretizing via some other
training yes there is
next question no I'm just joking I'll
explain you I'll explain you how in just
a second
I don't know this is
the problem but how exactly does the
function that creates the normal
distribution of people
oh how does that work ask me after class
but I think I talked about it earlier
um basically there's this thing called a
CDF it's a beautiful thing if you take
the CD off of the normal you're sampling
from it turns out you choose a random
value between 0 and 1 and you inverse
transform onto that CDF and you return
back this goes back to the user
so you start here choose
your y of the CDF
and figure out which X would lead to
that y give that to user and it gives
you a proper sample it's a beautiful
thing
okay
I'm not going to teach you this but I'm
going to teach you that it exists there
is this thing called Markov chain Monte
Carlo
it is a cool algorithm if you want to go
beyond rejection sampling rejection
sampling works for so many cases
especially if you're just a little bit
thoughtful about your discretizations
but I did want you to know that there
are other things out there and Markov
chain Monte Carlo does the same thing as
rejection sampling but look at my
samples notice anything funny
you're like hahaha everyone has a fever
that's not funny Chris they've got a
fever that's scary
the interesting thing about this is even
though I'm pulling samples every single
sample that I pull from has exactly the
query in it
so it's like set the query to be 101 and
then choose the other random variables
to be correct given that the query is
that number and then you don't have to
reject anything
how would you pull a sample like this is
beyond cs109 it's super cool you can go
check it out out
um but you know it's the next algorithm
if you were to learn Beyond rejection
sampling rejection sampling gets you so
far but there are other ones there's
mcmc there's actually even a package
written by Noah Goodman called pyro so
that uh you can just write this in code
and then the code will choose which
algorithm it should use to do inference
a beautiful thing
and then we even wrote One in our lab uh
for idea to text and I'd love to tell
you just a little bit about this do you
guys want to hear about something cool
yay okay so I'm gonna motivate this by a
problem that doesn't feel like WebMD at
all the problem that I'm going to
motivate this cool algorithm for is how
can we figure out what mistakes students
have made so imagine students trying to
write code to draw this thing and if you
think about this like that's pretty
annoying code to write you have to have
like nested for Loops there's a whole
bunch of things changing it's very
mind-blowing for a new student and
they're going to write it using a block
based language there are solutions are
probably about 10 lines or less but you
need to then be able to say what is the
feedback I should give you your
inference task is feedback given code
those are hard random variables to think
about aren't they
and long story short
we wanted to use rejection sampling
something like it so what did that mean
we needed to be able to write we need to
write a python function called sample
and when you write this python function
called sample it's going to make a fake
student with all of their misconceptions
and all of their code
and if we could write this sampling
algorithm
then we could sample a ton
and then we can look out of all the fat
sampled fake students have we ever get
all the students who have exactly this
code and we could look at all the
students who had exactly this code and
we could say okay what misconceptions
did they have what's the distribution of
people who didn't understand for Loops
here what's the distribution of people
who didn't understand if statements so
all we had to do was write a sampling
function and we were inspired by this
picture you're like what is going on in
this picture in 2015 somebody wrote one
of the more influential papers in our
field
and all that they really had to do in
this paper was write a function that was
called sample but instead of just
sampling a regular random variable it
was sampling hand-drawn digits so
imagine you have somebody trying to
write this digit
and you know there's all these other
characters and you might be trying to
figure out what's the probability that
what they've drawn is this character as
opposed to this character
well what they had is they had a
sampling algorithm they wrote a
generator boy they should have used
python in their paper they wrote this
crazy Insanity which is basically a mask
around python where they would you know
sample curves sample connections of
those curves sample how people put those
um components together
um and then from those they could just
write a four generative process and end
up with pictures of hand-drawn
characters and I said if they can sample
hand-drawn characters we can sample code
they sampled a lot of hand-drawn
characters and they got very good
results they beat all the neural
networks at the time
and so the idea was can you do this for
code and so we just thought okay we're
gonna write sample
and when we write sample we're just
going to try and generatively think
through a student's decision process
okay they decide to work on this problem
that's where they went wrong okay and
then we said then we would set all their
misconceptions and then based on their
misconception if we would start to
generate the code probabilistically and
we would sample from The Joint as much
as possible it's like we made the
Bayesian Network but for code and we
wrote a particular library that would
allow us to write the Bayesian Network
for code and it worked really really
really well and to the point where like
you could write this Bayesian Network
teachers don't know the generative
process does anyone know the Bayesian
Network for how a student thinks no
there wasn't like a place I could go
research and look up what is the
Bayesian Network we did have to invent
it based on just what we thought
students would do
but generative is not so hard if you're
thinking generatively it's like making
the WebMD model it's not that hard you
can be like okay I think flu causes
fever that's not insane and similarly
you can be like if people have this
misconception I've seen them write this
piece of code it wasn't insane for us to
write this and it turned out to be very
very useful and not just for code we
used it on code we used it on
um short answers and by we I mean some
wonderful scientists which also included
our own headtea actually the first time
I met will
like a freshman you came here like I
want to do some research I'm like no
sorry I'm just joking but you're like
hey can I have a challenge for for
winter break and I said well we're
thinking a lot about these sampling
things could you sample I think it was
Graphics I gave you a graphics thing I
said people who are in 106a they do a
pyramid assignment can you sample people
drawing pyramids and you sample the ton
will and it was part of this wonderful
research project that seemed to work
very well
um so you know we wrote the decision
making Bayesian Network and then we
would sample a ton
where you get a bunch of fake students
with fake code and then we would do
inference we could have used rejection
sampling that would have worked pretty
well I do want to be honest that we also
used a little bit of a neural network to
make our rejection sampling a little bit
more efficient but rejection sampling
would have been fine for inference uh
just there was because we could we used
a slightly different one
now before I let you go I just want to
make this a little bit more relevant
you guys should be asking yourselves
this question
oh here's one of the weirdest things you
could ask yourself while studying for a
midterm
what is you look at a problem and you're
like what's the probability that this is
a binomial distribution problem right
isn't that what you're kind of doing and
in fact if you want to really solve that
you know what you should do
you should write a Bayesian Network you
should think what's the generative
process through which Chris creates
binomial distribution problems
and if you could write that Bayesian
Network you would know everything about
how to solve any cs109 binomial
distribution problem right wouldn't that
be cool
so I went ahead and did that for you
guys I wrote a generative model
and when you run it I think it I think
currently it just creates like a hundred
random binomial distribution problems uh
and sorry they're written all in HTML
with latex in them
um but it'll say something like a ball
hit a series of 30 pins where it can
bounce either to left or the right the
probability of a right on each pin is
one-third what is the probability that
the number of writes is 28.
did somebody just write the answer
it doesn't say the answer oh there is
the answer oh there it is it's very very
low
um but anyways I sampled that I just
like had a distribution for it and you
know potentially using some rejection
sampling or something like mcmc or
something more complicated you could put
this as your query and you can say what
is the probability that this is binomial
given the query or you could even say
what's the probability of the answer you
can even say what's the answer given the
query
um anyways
but that is an interesting thing of a
way to talk about
um studying for a midterm is to try and
write your own that's maybe one takeaway
I can't write that many problems I'm an
old man I've written many midterms I'm
running out of creativity and there's
only so many ways you can ask about
binomials and poissons and all those
things I probably have a generative
process in my mind
and if you tried to write your own
midterm you would have to generate you
would have to get into the generative
process and maybe by thinking about that
you would get really good at the
inference task because one of the
stories of Bayesian networks is the
ability to generate is an important
precursor to the ability to infer
okay
um I'll just tell you what we haven't
talked about
as I mentioned there is a field of study
where you can learn the arrows from data
that's called structure learning we
haven't talked about this and we haven't
particularly talked about how you can
get these probabilities basically I've
told you to make them up so far but it
turns out that there are data driven
ways you could do this if I gave you
some historical data you could infer
these probabilities pretty well
I hope you guys have a fantastic weekend
study for the midterm we'll see you guys
there's no class on Monday see you guys
on Tuesday or Wednesday have a fantastic
weekend I'll be thinking about you guys
a lot come to the review session that
starts in 40 minutes